[Música]
[Aplausos]
pollo frito
y viendo cosas en youtube pensando hacia
un nuevo hoy que estoy haciendo
y no pude encontrar ninguna mejor
explicación o un tipo de narrativa buena
para mis preguntas
si no fuera por la ayuda de youtube
donde encontré el vídeo de las charlas
del valle de chalco original si saben
cuáles son
las gafas aquí significa en tristeza
aquí de un barrio pesado y atrás
la espalda
[Música]
yo quería saber que todo este trino todo
este tren de las charlas y la gente
haciendo sus memes
esta onda divertida entonces dije bueno
pues tengo 15 minutos vamos a quitarnos
el vídeo
viendo el vídeo empiezo a ver que las
gafas acá mi barrio de la pañoleta que
usábamos tiene este significado que si
le hacemos así pues también y que si me
estás amedrantando pues yo te respondan
de decir y ya embolada más y con el
pollo de hay dos emociones feliz y este
y entonces algo que me trajo de esto fue
que para ser parte de las cholas y
cholos tienen que hacer un círculo
grande entras tú y lo entres morrás
dependiendo el sexo no si nos entran
tres gatos y te golpean por 13 segundos
si podemos hacer un círculo aquí
proforma jajajaja hagamos de iniciación
texto si no se iniciaran entonces me
pareció muy curioso que empiezan hacer
el círculo y en eso
[Música]
a este se empiezan a golpear y ya se
empieza a contarnos 10 10 10 ya es
comunicarnos el presión existe el reloj
y lo repite un chorro a veces más hasta
que gana los 13 y todos van y abrazan
esta mujer sola hélice en bienvenida a
la familia cuando van y la entrevista en
a la mujer le dicen qué onda cómo te
sientes qué está pasando y ya bien bien
vienen cosas peores
me empecé a tocar de la risa y qué está
pasando en esta mujer y yo quise
entender yo no sintiendo mejor en
calzones tragando y queriendo su vídeo
mientras ella sí estacionario yo hay que
tengo que ser ellos para hacer lo mejor
en la vida
aprendiendo de esto me puse a pensar y
analizar lo que estamos dijo me di
cuenta que esta mujer es increíble
ella tiene lugar allí con los filósofos
saca un platón con sócrates está en otro
nivel está mora sabe y me puse a pensar
porque dije sí es cierto en la vida
vienen cosas peores entonces empecé a
aplicarlo a mi vida quise analizar mis
primeros 13 segundos que son relativos
lazado porque los primeros duraron un
año y medio desde que nacemos jana los
míos
así que acompáñenme ver esta triste
historia
yo empecé una marca y en esta marca
empecé con ropita accesorios y demás
pero algo que quería hacer era grabar
vídeos yo quería hacer la próxima lluvia
cuarentonas es enseñar yo para lluvia
y estando en eso yo grava a mis médicos
en mi cocina pasada a mi mamá y yo las
hago es como están aquí en este nuevo
día igual
es entidad especial y sima
y empecé a subir vídeos pero yo tengo un
chorro de miedo porque la raza cuando
está detrás de la computadora es bien
valiente y todos tienen sus comentarios
y cómo puedes ser anónimo cómo puedes
poner tu nombre pues yo dije el nombre
como la raza después a mí me van a
atacar primer método una lista y dije
bueno uno que otro insulto en un vídeo
lo puedo aguantar pues para eso está la
grasa anders entonces
empezó a ir bien a la raza le encantó
que padre música me encanta hacía vídeos
de que tú player es la bufanda y
aprovecha reciclar reusar y todo ese
triple hasta que un día lleva facebook y
de un menú inbox en el mensaje de otros
y yo hachís cuando le picó veo que era
un hombre y yo
ya sea de la fecha ya entonces cuando
preparo las velitas para ver este
mensaje hay el hermetizado veo que me
manda esto no lo voy a leer con todo
respeto ustedes
no wey estoy viendo esto como se
te ocurre hablar de moda si eres una
nata y voy punto hacer ejercicio seguro
eres una gorda sin novio de forma el
cuerpo mira te tienes unos 30 años
wayport en la onda eso que haces en esta
página es para gente pobre güey debes
vivir en la periferia a quien le
interesa esto
como sabe que no tengo novio
qué está pasando acá somos tan
desesperadas mis videos alguien a mí me
parte a mis papás por favor jajajaja
toda la lista que tenía todo momento ahí
gorda de forma
ya me reglas si no había 30 años
prefiere qué está pasando yo tenía miedo
porque yo generalmente en comillas en
esas cosas me voy a quebrar me voy a
destruir y voy a dejar mi sueño ya no
voy a subir vídeos y cuando lo vi dije
que te pasa guasa y por su pollo que a
seguir subiendo vídeos esto además es
fueguito porque yo entendí que este
hombre pues tenía envidia o lo que
quiera se estaba proyectando y él quería
hacer lo que estaba haciendo pero no lo
hacía porque él tenía miedo que los van
a criticar a juzgar y que le mandaran
mensajes como el mensaje que él me mandó
a mí así que decidí mira yo me lavo las
manos me bloqueó no le pude responder
y seguí con mi camino y ese fue un
primer madrazo que aguante resistir y
dije pues tierra vamos a ver que me pasa
el otro madrazo fue que cuando hice mi
emprendimiento tomé la peor decisión
y asociarme con quien era mi mejor amiga
y las cosas no quedaron bien y quedamos
de signo como giovanni silva de
cómplices al rescate si es que bien sabe
que chido
las cosas no fueron padres tuvimos que
separarnos y fue otro golpe porque fue
la primera vez que perdí a una persona
sigue viva pero pero fue alguien que se
fue a mi vida y fue una de las cosas que
más me dolió porque tú crees que la
amistad el amor todo es para siempre y
no sabía que esa amistad tiene una fecha
causa las dos
no entiendo qué pasa
tomo la decisión yo estaba viendo en
tamaulipas 16 que nos agarró mis cosas
vengo con la bendición de mi abuelita y
no venimos para monterrey con el éxito y
el dinero que traía en mi bolsillo que
me dieron mis papás
en cuando llegó y dije necesito buscar
chamba porque no puedo estar siendo
emprendedoras y no tengo lana y si mis
papás me están dando pues me va a sentir
muy falsa realidad
digo una vez y me enterar pero pues yo
sabía yo
soy diseñador gráfico busco chamba no
encontraba yo que está pasando saben mis
diseños tú ves que no encontrará algo
si alguien lo entienda
llega un lugar a barrio me contratan al
instante este señor un trucho toro
increíble de esas personas que intimidan
que sabes que si ya le caes te vine
alarma es que la vida o sea yo ya tengo
guardaespaldas aquí jajaja carga me a
llevarme a mi cubículo
entonces este hombre me contrata el
instante y yo emocionada sin saber que
estaba entrando a las mismas puertas del
infierno qué está pasando
entre esta chamba me doy cuenta que
todas las barras que trabajan ahí eran
modelos modelos entonces nos ponía se
enfila era de que y luego yo un meme se
parece a la tía de ella
yo pensé que eso no iba a repercutir
hasta que un día llega este hombre me
dice oye que tengo que hablar contigo
sabes que a mí me preocupa la imagen de
mi empresa tú no eres imagen y me da
pena que tengan los clientes después y
al fondo de la oficina porfa
pues que me voy a la cueva a silencio el
lugar más frío sin luz pero con un
internado
netflix de bendición sobre las cosas
malas
aquí nadie me molesta estando en esa
chamba la verdad es que nunca ha vivido
tanto humillación esta persona me odiaba
me trataba muy mal y me doy cuenta que
yo con dos carreras estaba ganando siete
mil pesos y la secretaria está ganando
16 mil lo que está pasando obviamente
agarrar el coraje contra el amar a los
ovarios y voy a pedirle la aumentan a no
creo que llego yo de qué onda
o la que está limpiada
el anterior aumento y el cuánto quieres
enojado cuánto quieres y yo dije ya lo
hermano quiero mil pesos extra
no estoy orgullosa mil pesos porque
cuarto para la renta de verdad
para mí esta persona no mía este año ese
año
mis cumpleaños con temática y ese año
había sido de cholos me está pasando y
él me dice no tuvieron un aumento y
tienes una queja mandemos whatsapp
no tiene celular verdad jajaja y así
como en película de canal 5 donde están
todos los morritos alrededor del niñito
del que se están probando así me empiezo
a sentir porque todos los bienes que me
dio y entonces tomé ese fue un golpe
terrible así fue un golpe fuerte y tomé
la decisión de sabes qué mejor agarro
mis cosas y me voy y me dolió me quebró
después vino otro golpe audicionó para
comer central curiosamente yo no le
quería entrar a la comedia la gente
después de mis conferencias decían que
juanita estándar y honor estándar pero
mi vida pero bueno que la gente amarillo
que audicionó para el comedy central y
la primera eran dos audiciones la
primera rey estuvo horrible quedé en
ridículo está todavía una bebé en
pañales para esto de la comedia y no
creo que me sentí decepcionada y de de
20 batos éramos cinco morrás y yo dije
no no necesitan trabajar en eso somos
bien poquitos mujeres me comen y la
verdad es que quien montar bien está tan
chido porque los gatos siempre se
quemaron la moral hay tres vueltas
emergencias y yo dije yo traigo todo
trip diferente yo me agarro al bando
[Risas]
[Música]
cambia de la gavia de la entonces
decepcionada dije no voy a ir a la
segunda audición aquí me voy a quedar en
mi propia miseria pero de esos golpes
que me está dando la vida capte que oye
porque si te estás motivando otras
personas aquí tú no te vas a motivar y
llegó y que en el top 5 porque en el top
5 de el comedy central you y fueron las
cosas más orgullosas porque todas las
moras nada más que yo y alrededor de
todos los otros batidos que me encantaba
pero cuando decíamos los ganadores de
expulsión al lado mío y yo en ilo me
acordé de que te están grabando
felicidades fue algo que me hizo
sentirme en la cima del mundo entonces
no creo que esa noche fue a festejar voy
al antro de un bato y yo va a ser mío no
hay otra y nadie nadie me va a tirar
entonces estábamos vestido eso
en ese cero al baño y cuando regrese a
lo que ya no viene conmigo y sada con
sus amigos y yo no entendí entonces yo
sutilmente me acerco nada que hola aquí
estaba ahí y escucho que dice está gorda
verdad
y en eso todo strip que traía de ganar
lo sentí que no valía nada si en ese
momento un medio en el madrazo y me
perdí un acorde que me fui a llorar me
fui a mi casa y empecé a llorar un
chorro y dije cuando me creo que es en
la dramática porque soy una matic isma
viéndome en el espejo agarrado de
lavadora cuando va a llegar alguien
quererme como soy
cuando me llegará alguien a verme tal y
como soy cuando alguien en vez de ver mi
físico a ver todo el trayecto y todas
las cosas que he hecho para poder ser
una mejor persona
tienes un me quedé callado y no observo
yo tonta como que cuando aquí estás eres
tú le puedes poner tu felicidad y la
forma en que tú quieres que se fija la
vida en las manos de otras personas
entonces ese día desde después de ese
embarazo me levanto y arme una lista 14
cosas porque llega a empezar febrero y
dije necesito hacer un reto un reto para
recordarme mi amor el amor que me
merezco todos los días 14 cosas e inicia
el primer febrero y termina el 14 porque
febrero para mí es el mes del amor pero
para ti y por ende los demás y salió el
iphone los meses entonces 14 retos y uno
de esos era tomarme una sesión de fotos
donde yo quería verme guapa yo quería
sentirme chida y de la forma en que se
pudiera y en brasier cita me voy digo a
una bebé cita y también en la zona
[Música]
me tomo esas fotos pasa el tiempo la
gente respondió bien chido y en eso me
el último día que tenía que subir las
fotos está nerviosa porque ya sé que la
gente iba a decir cosas me iba a poner
este tren a solas antes de subir las
fotos abro mi celular y porque tenía un
mensaje en mi página y yo bitches cuando
vio el mensaje en una chava que me dice
estuve viendo tu reto te estoy siguiendo
los 14 días me gustó muchísimo yo no
estoy lista para hacerlo yo todavía no
lo puedo hacer no me puedo decir 14
cosas que me gustan no puedo bailar no
pasar nada porque no me siento pero te
quiero decir algo yo estaba listo para
quitarme la vida y viturro te dije un
día más
el tema celular
también el feeling
[Risas]
me quedé callada me queda nada pensé no
ibas a hacer el reto llevaba a leer te
pusiste a pensar en lo que la gente iba
a decir y luego se deje pasar pero lo
hiciste por qué pensaste en ti y no para
los demás entonces continuó leyendo y me
dice me salvaste la vida eligen borrar
tu me acabas de definir qué es lo que
tengo que hacer yo con la mía así que yo
te tengo que agradecer a ti no
la vida nos jode por esto es algo
que tengo bien claro quiero que me dejo
esta cosa de las charlas de chalco estos
trece madrazos que se dan estos trece
segundos de madrazos que se dan que la
vida te prepara para las cosas esas
cosas que tú crees que no vas a aguantar
que tú crees que pagamos no nos va bien
que ahorita ya sabes lo acepté y acepto
vulnerabilidad y la quiero y la amo y
estas lágrimas que entonces me da
vergüenza las muestro porque este es
como mi sudor sabes el sudor del alma de
las cosas que he vivido y de las
madrazas que me dio la vida pero te
quiero decir que tus primeros trece
madrazos que son relativos los primeros
tres segundos
tomar tus maras y te van a quebrar y te
vas a caer y te van a pisar y vas a
sentir que no te vas a poder levantar
pero lo vas a hacer te vas a levantar
sus segundos más grasos te van a dar y
vas a esquivar una que otro golpe pero
te van a volver a dar y te van a volver
a pisar pero te vas a volver a levantar
y los terceros te van a dar y vas a
estar bien parado y parada y te van a
dar los madrazos y los vas a recibir y
vas a estar listo y ese estilo mayor de
los respondo sin miedo alguno entonces
quiero que vean la belleza de esta
filosofía que cada una de las cosas
malas que les pasa tiene un significado
no es un porque es un para que analice
el para qué me está pasando esto para
que yo sea mejor persona para ello tener
una piel dura para poder aguantar y para
saber cuando tengo que decir que no y
cuando tengo que decir que si la vida no
te jode por sabe que dentro de ti
hay algo súper especial tú sabes tú
sabes que está la llamita aquí dentro de
ti donde dices es que si georgia
al es que si yo le hablara al es que si
yo buscara y no la puedes callar la vida
va a decir es que si no lo hizo es
madrazos no lo va a sacar y lo voy o sea
no fue la espera más rápida como para
regándola en la vida que por favor
piensen eso que ustedes se fueron a
millones y este dinero hay que ganar ya
darle con la vida
está muy rica que está allí es mi hija
nadie
soy yo soy muy joven aguante en el bar
pero no voy a hablar de eso ahorita que
está ahí jamás pensó que después de seis
años de estar viviendo estas cosas iba a
poder estar aquí parada
con una resiliencia y con una fuerza y
poder contarles las cosas que están
viviendo porque yo sé que hay gente que
ve cosas peores pero mínimo que un
poquito lo que yo estoy diciendo si una
semillita que ya te guardo que ya te
quedó en ti ya te friegas porque ya no
te vas a poder quitar perdón perdóname
pero si se puede no hay nada que es
imposible se los prometo yo empecé con
un pantalón y un collar roto en mi casa
con un tutorial en youtube para aprender
a coser y crear lo que ahorita estoy
haciendo y cada vez voy mejorando y
ahorita yo solamente le digo la vida
fierro como
o con lo que sea
aquí estoy lista para recibir más maras
así que muchísimas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]